another appearance on this program for
one of my favorites from one of my
favorite shows beep again we had Sam
Richardson on yesterday veep is gonna be
on HBO this very Sunday night at 10:30
p.m. Eastern Time in its final season
mr. Tony Hale to time I mean you told me
Sam busted up his knee he did did you
not know that I did not know that that's
what he did it weightlifting or
something said What did he say it was
well he was squatting he was she was
school barbells squatting okay look I
never met him before
oh he's the nicest man I know so then
let's talk ill of him because because I
don't know if that is again if I blew
out my knee and I just like tripped on
something I I would say yeah I was
barbell press in yeah and he slipped
it's an ice cream shop so something like
that how realistic is it to know it's
very it's probably the word is he worked
out in the set you know if he's got a
regimen I don't I mean I'm sure he does
okay I just the picture of him I think
with a barbell and blowing out his knee
I mean I'm gonna call later I do have
some questions though can I guess my
question yes yes you may okay when you
guys were talking before there's two
words that were mentioned that we're
disturbing to me okay one one definitely
was disturbing the other one was
confusing okay
the word offloading yes is that a is
that a popular in the sports glossary
you say oh well you offload something I
forget honestly I don't remember the and
that means I guess in which I said it
somebody was offloaded come on who wants
to be told that obviously that's like
rejection to another team I assume know
you've been offloaded guys a program or
something it's dark turn well it's funny
is well that there's been there has been
it might have been about Josh Rosen oh
yeah they got offload yes that that the
current quarterback of the Arizona
Cardinals is about to lose his job
because there's gonna be a new kid
drafted and he so they must then
offloaded a right now fired is a
softer turn than awful it's like we're
gonna have to let you go I'm sorry
you're offloaded off the truck well it's
funny too that there has been this year
by the way you can back me up on this
Chris there has been a new term that I
had never heard before and it is in
relation to NBA players when they are
rested over the last several years
players players would just sit out games
and they like say LeBron James would sit
out a game in a town where he's only
going through once and the fans who
bought their tickets to see LeBron James
were so upset so they came up with a
term that when they rest the player it's
for it's definitely you know it's for
health reasons and the term is load
management all right well let's break
that when somebody is hurt no I don't
think somebody gets in trouble no no
when that when they're rested when they
just need a they need to take a game off
James is not playing tonight and the
reason why because you have to give a
term and an injury report load
management god I don't even get uneven
no wouldn't know how to break that down
like the load load they're carrying I
guess trying to manage that load it
could be but didn't you say something if
they got in trouble or if they were load
management again load is is a is a
charged word potentially yeah sure yeah
yeah there's a lot of definitions to
that but why would they why would they
not just to say hey let's give him a
rest no no I think it's just it first of
all makes too much sense
secondly is that is it a fan if they're
told LeBron James is resting tonight
like I paid so much money for these
tickets so I kids have been waiting to
see LeBron James I show up and he's
resting oh yeah it's safe well kids
LeBron James isn't playing tonight he's
he's uh it's it's a load management
problem and all of a sudden you're like
oh my god they say like a soul
management or
something like spiritual managing doing
some sort of tantric so here's my other
question whose little finger okay all
right okay character in Game of Thrones
do you not watch game don't watch Game
of Thrones all your I know I should this
protection program for not why she came
with drones people here's the thing I
watched the first episode they pushed
the kid out the window and I was like
I'm out like those white dogs or
something like that sort of you know
hurting them and I heard about I heard
all about the red wedding and everybody
lost her right away it's like there's
just i'll watch CNN and be just as
depressed you know it's there's a lot
there's a lot I know it's a great show
and I know people love it but it's a lot
visually the sound design all that blood
squirting yeah that's a lot to hear say
just so you just that's it yeah you're
one and done a guy I don't see horror
movies who wants to go see paranormal
activity don't get it don't mess with
that I'm not the guy that's gonna see
some of them be like oh I'm gonna have a
nice sleep something's coming after ya
I'm not into that either there's enough
fear in society to put yourself through
that and violence in society from the
way true Game of Thrones a different
story though I mean I know it's I know
it's a wonderful show it's a lot
visually it is it's a lot and it's gonna
deliver a hell of a rating right veep on
Sunday night yes it is and I'm very
thankful for this I'm very thankful for
G ot that's the one lingo I know you got
it yeah people do love it but who is
little finger little finger did you
watch the wire did you ever watch the
luck end come on
that's like keep in mind my wife watches
all of these shifts so yeah you don't
you don't part is the I'm also the guy
that I would watch if the office got
uncomfortable I would go to the kitchen
I'm just like just fire the guy just get
rid of them why is he still in the
office
this could off of the office so what
Tony Hale here on the Rich Eisen show
what do you watch I watch a lot of
YouTube okay
I don't mind watching people get scared
like I the most recent one as I watched
you know Ellen sends those people
through a haunted house sure I think
that's really funny I don't want to go
through a haunted house
I mean people jumping out but watching
people read it I do think that's funny I
also watch a lot of compilation videos
oh I watch soldiers coming home to their
dogs I think it's really makes me cry
okay so you send in what else do i watch
I always watched you know those the
voice or but I only want to see when
people win it's like you know like when
like if they have a good blind audition
and the family freaks out in the end
yeah I think that's really joyful to
watch so I like those but I don't want
to see anybody reject it so I don't want
to see the bad American Ninja Warrior do
you watch any I have seen that with my
daughter my daughter knives my kids
can't it's a little nominating so know
that we're not the warrior or did we'd
have any ninja there's a lot of CrossFit
but yeah but like beyond CrossFit you
know just like who climbs have you seen
free soul oh yes I have seen frozed free
solo have you seen it it's the scariest
thing how many people saw free solo not
knowing what it is they thought it was
about Han and the Carbonite and they
thought it was something to do with Star
Wars
probably
and they're all like what is this thing
okay so that's two those documentaries
this is a side note but that made me
think when I worked at this thing called
it was like a Nautilus Museum in
Virginia Beach's when my first jobs
called Nautilus and people thought it
was a water park and they showed up in
their bathing suits and they were very
pissed off number-one workout places
were referred to as a Nautilus what do
you work there what did you do I was the
Nutty Professor and did science
experiments for the kids and it was a
summer job it was called Nautilus it was
a great job but it just opened and it
was a water you know experience and
people thought it was a water park and
all these kids it was just incredibly
disappointing so were you looking after
the kids when people were working out
and here's that one that was no no it
wasn't it wasn't a work out thing it was
like a aquarium slash you know touch the
eel that kind of a thing like an
aquarium experience but people thought
it was a water park anyways that was a
little ATD moment what are you saying do
you watch beep yes I do watch me but I
only watch my scenes on loop that's
really but do you you'd say you do watch
I do I do i do love because it's uh yes
I do I do
again it's it's because it's I mean it's
it's a funny show the language is
definitely rough it is that and and
Jonah Ryan
Tim Simons plays him he gets the worst
insults I think one time somebody said
but said you have a weird shape to him
once I think he was called cloud
disturber oh he was called and I'll beep
this out but he was called Frankenstein
if Frankenstein was made entirely of
dead Deas that was actually ad libbed by
Zach woods there's a really bad one that
I won't say there's actually several
I was called a [ __ ] mime
I was also called Kauai's just use
whatever sticks
obviously we improv to just hurt each
other just find the most insecurity and
just point it out he's Arrested
Development the same way no that's um I
know uh well Buster definitely get what
did he get um well he was just kind of
oh he was yeah he was just in a state of
paralysis all this I think he was
completely checked out he would have
heard it if somebody said it to her like
now you have heard the look the Liza
Minnelli story we have on the show we
have hid this story before yes yeah oh
and when I when we when she took my wife
and I out to lunch no the one that he
told you the last time that he drove her
oh that's right yes we did talk about
their often whose house did you drop
Scott bad that's right
sure sure what's the lunch tracks what's
the track what's your lunch story with
Liza
she took my wife and I out to lunch
she's by the way a lovely woman amazing
amazing woman and she because I just
want to make sure that she really is
it's not a she's a fantastic woman she
started talking about this concert she
was doing it Radio City Music Hall and I
didn't know her music and she's sitting
in the back seat chain-smoking
and she goes well I'll sing you a song
and started belting out the song Liza
with a Z in the backseat of my car and
the best thing is she had heard it so
much she could hear the orchestration so
she'd go
and I was like oh this is the best
moment of my life
people either thought she was Joyce
DeWitt from Three's Company my mother or
an impersonator of herself Oh
think that was really Liza Minnelli now
and she would the best thing I've said
when she would sit in a chair oh man I
loved everything about her and she would
tell me stories about her mom and I Matt
she loved a mom yeah but the way she
would sit mr. chair was like nobody else
she would sit like this like she was
just about to break into cabaret at any
moment please break out into cabaret so
that's how she would just sit in a chair
she's I mean she's just ready she's
always ready she's a dancer and she's
always got stories and her this is a
great thing her stories never came from
a place of ego they just came from a
place of like listen to my life you know
and I was just like keep talking she was
great right that's so rare that that she
could just tell these childhood stories
about she was raised on the MGM lot
right that's where she that's where she
grew up
yeah I was I was raised in Staten Island
New York there was nothing like that
she flew from Tallahassee yeah the home
of the yes yes yes actually speaking of
southern sports am I talking too long no
okay Tony Hale here on the Richard
speaking of southern sports you'll
appreciate this
my niece got married this past weekend
it was my wife's niece so I guess that
means it's my niece as well yes yes and
we were at the wedding and there was a
big crisis because Albarn was playing
yes in the final fool in the Final Four
of Virginia yes okay they had to learn
we would go I'd hear like well win and
win and win and I was like when you say
we're let's just break this down but
they had they had there was a lot of
phone calls for the wedding that were
like I just wanna know do you guys have
a TV at the reception like people were
very very scared and they had one on the
on the second floor of this barn and
everybody gathered for the game barn but
in actuals are the collard greens and
shrimps and grits and barbecue were on
this first floor and they had this TV on
the second floor that all they watched
the Auburn Virginia game did you watch
the game with no no no no I danced to
the band because I felt bad for that guy
that feels for the band oh yeah I mean
everybody it was just like a mass exodus
up to the balcony and they were just
playing their country tunes so I just
danced with him and me I don't know if
you noticed at some point that there was
all the excitement that an Auburn fan
thought the game was over and then they
did not okay
disappointed well I probably should have
asked more questions about this but
during the okay towards the end I felt
like there was a lot of confusion if we
win we didn't win we win we didn't want
correct because wasn't it like at 5959
or something like gore burn was up by
three right okay great with mere seconds
to go Virginia took a shot they missed
it Auburn won except for the fact that
the winning masked the sound of a
whistle calling a foul on the shot in
the cave three free-throws
oh that poor kid yeah right now that was
that was the one that they won that game
from the free-throw line
yeah two-point game it was a two-point
game and he made all three well it was a
massive buzzkill man to get to that 5959
like tied at the end that's yes that was
proud of whoever lost yes come on you
got there sounds like a man who walks
out on the uncomfortable parts of the
office just like and be kind let's just
like each other okay let's talk about
veep before I let you go off into this
Los Angeles day sir I miss it already
just watching every episode it's just
like oh it's wonderful it's like eating
candy and then you know the depression
that out there's only a certain amount
of it that's still remaining yeah well
you are watching this stuff right now
it's hard man I mean we should we
finished shooting in December and I'm
sure Sam said this as well but like we
really like each other like we those
first four years when we were shooting
we shot in Baltimore right and so we got
really close we would like go out for
drinks after shooting and talk about the
day and then we'd go to Julia's and play
cards as we kind of we were away from
each other's family so we got became
each of this family what sort of cards
are you playing at we played oh gosh it
was a I forgot what it was called this
is because this was four years ago
okay but you would play yeah we play
cards and drink wine and I forgot and we
played it all the time no limit hold'em
was it the note wasn't that okay eight
yes is an eight no okay use me
excuse me mr. gambling we got really
close and so like it was really tough to
just say goodbye to the relationships
and also just to do material that you
know you always knew when you got a
script it was gonna be a lot of
surprises and funny really funny it is
so funny it is so very funny and then of
course Arrested Development you've been
in some funny stuff man very thankful
very thankful
absolutely and tell me about your book
tell me about your York oh this is
really exciting because you your first
time you were here you were promoting as
well a kids book yeah kind of to give me
to my kids and they they read it thank
you for that so I did this book with my
friends Toni and Victor years ago called
Archibald's next big thing because when
I booked Arrested Development I realized
I was still looking to the next thing
and missing where I was okay and it's
that whole thing if you're gonna be so
focused on your next adventure you'll
miss the adventure you're on so then it
became a cartoon with my friends Drew
and Jake and Eric and and now he's a
very he's a chicken that is very present
and walks into a situation and he not
only sees the best in people but he sees
the best in the situation and he makes a
lot of mistakes but he knows there's a
bigger purpose for the mistake in it and
if this attitude shows but he's just
like incredibly positive and it's like
man in our world today we need a lot
more of that so I'm it's gonna be out in
the fall on Netflix it's called what is
it it's called Archibald's next big
thing Archer bolts next and in the book
he has this will be that goes around
with him and it's like you gotta just be
man okay I like it and so it's really
really fun and
life giving and I'm excited about the
thing in the present yes that is that's
good advice sir yeah well I and I need
it too I struggle with it every day yeah
so do I unfortunately our present is now
past because I've you've got to go hi so
do you guys have to go to over there
veep on HBO Sunday nights at 10:30 p.m.
Eastern Time
thank you for the laughs or not just
thank you for her but veep and arrested
for being such a support man anytime I
love this watched it thank you for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app